this one is pretty wild how what it's
awesome it's not like crazy wild but
it's if you've ever seen the water boy
bobby bushy
this story is a shout out to him
my mama's here so this is a basically
story about what it's like to be an nfl
water boy right we
listen football sundays monday night
football then it's thursday night
players tom brady aaron rodgers everyone
you know derek henry best running back
in the league you know all these players
that are going out out there but what's
it like to be the water boy what's it
like to be the real life a bobby boucher
let me hear your best bobby boucher
my mom she
because they have a small brain
they got all those teeth and no
toothbrush you brush them
you do a good bobby boucher it's all in
the jaw
that's so good
anyway anybody wants to be a water bot
after seeing their quote unquote insane
salary so here's what's going on so
obviously an nfl water boy's job is to
do one thing
keep your players hydrated h2
[Laughter]
it's h2o
exactly they get you know they're like
the liquid god shout out to bobby
boucher who made being a water boy
infamous i believe that movie came out
in 1999
if i if i so how much do you think a
starting salary for nfl water boy is
if the okay i'll give you a number the
whole thing is that they make a lot uh a
starting salary 100k no
aggressive you went over the top
starting salary for a young water boy
for a young bobby boucher
is 53 000 a year just to start out but
as you uh become better with the water
[Laughter]
the numbers go up you can make six
figures over a professional six
waterfalls if you
stick it out if you stick it out if you
bring if you work your way up to the
until you lead water boy a wider man
[Laughter]
you start off as a water boy make a 53
degree what a man making up hundreds
you're water man
david you're killing on this episode so
it seems like nothing of a job right
just bring the guys their water right
but
if in my opinion it's all about
opportunity what kind of opportunity
opportunity basically to be on the field
every single game so if you're a
football fan boom you're working you're
there you got front row seats okay
you're on the field on game you
basically have season tickets for free
you're you know you're not you're not
dude working too hard better be making
six figures if my son has to go to
school and say my dad's uh
the water boy
[Laughter]
i mean
you get to you get to mix it up with the
players you get to hydrate the players
you
[Laughter]
you know but the the the
the thing with uh the water boy
is that it's a it's a starting job like
any starting job right you got to work
your way up the most important thing is
that you can create relationships like
like bobby boucher yeah he created a
relationship with the coach right yeah
exactly a coach coach klein
[Music]
knows every [ __ ] character from every
adam
anyway just like any profession we're
making fun of the water but we're having
a fun time it's a this is attainment
type of store we're talking about the
water boy how much money they make 50
freaking g's they get the players their
waters
but basically what the water boys do is
they find something this is the first
shout out to all the people out there
they find something that they're
passionate about they love it whether
it's hydration h2o or actual football
they're like dude i gotta figure out a
way to get close to the team to the
coach start somewhere i'll start i'll do
anything essentially the coffee guy for
the players you're the coffee guy for
the players i'll bring you the coffee i
like that analogy yeah you're bringing
you to watch yeah yeah um but you got to
start from the bottom just like in
anything you start from the bottom and
then you stay at the bottom making sense
thank you just stay there making water
bro
uh and then maybe you work your way up
right what gatorade guy like
who knows what you don't think that you
know that okay the you know yeah i know
you're not a basketball guy but i'm
gonna quiz you here go ahead the coach
of the miami heat do you know his name
sculptured of course you know yeah i
love i love it okay cool so eric
spoelstra absolute legend legend he's
probably 50 i'm guessing okay
he started off as the as the filmmaker
the video guy yeah the video guy did
that for five years he's doing video
he's watching tape he's the essentially
the water boy but just for video okay
now he's the freaking head coach of the
freaking miami heat you're saying i
could be three championships under his
belt
i'm just saying you gotta start
somewhere you gotta get your foot in the
door you ever hear that story about pat
used to do when he sent someone a shoe
pardon you don't know the story no he
says look he sends somebody like
somebody's trying to do business with a
shoe
right a single shoe a single shoe okay
and there's a note on it and says
now that i got my foot in the door
how about you come meet me in person
and that's a very creative approach this
guy sent me a shoe this guy sent me a
shoe who throws a shoe who gets beat
with a shoe
who throws a shoe so anyway you got to
start from the bottom to work your way
up great relationships you know so this
guy he started from the bottom he's
making 50 freaking gs to hydrate he gets
an all-access pass field pass to give
water and he gets all the liquids he can
drink not a bad gig to be the nfl water
boy what are the credentials
have you ever poured something into a
cup right there's probably not a lot of
do we froze in here are we good
no we're good we're good all right we're
good anyway nf nfl water boy for 50 g's
so here's the question for you david and
our friends at home
who's your favorite team
uh nfl no in the world chelsea chelsea
you got joe you got tattoos of chelsea
you
if you could basically be the chelsea
water 100
i'll do it for free you do it for free
you would do it
so if your favorite team is the buffalo
bills or the new england patriots or the
you know ellie rams whatever your
favorite freaking team is green bay
packers i could go down the list here
yeah right houston texans i could go
down the list and they're like yeah
you're the water boy we're gonna pay you
50 gs and just bring the people water
and have a great time and just don't
don't [ __ ] poison the players you
would do it keep your money kings i'll
do it for free
you would do it for free that's what
passion is my friend that's passion i
have to i have to go it's a passion for
water i gotta go apply that's it if you
enjoyed that short clip from the sauce
cast click here to watch another click
here to watch the full episode or just
stay bro
[Music]